みなさんこんにちは
8ですね今日はですねあの cm の話ではなくてですね
アングル視点の話きょうしようと思います
僕はずっと広告クリエイターとして愛でを考える人とずっとやってきたんですね
一つ発見したことがあるんですけども
それっていうのは人はすごい優れたアイディアんで行った時に必ずある一言が心にむか
分ですね
その一言っていうのは何なのかというとその手があったかっていう一言が必ずここに
浮かぶんですよ
なんでそれに気付かなかったんだろうって同じものを見ていたのになんでそれに気付か
なかったんだろうって優れたアイディアやあればあるほど
そういう感覚に襲われるんですね
その同じものを見ているのにちょっとした違いでアイディアが激しく
飛躍するというそのちょっとした地点の違いを
まあ another angle と言います
これは僕が4日前名付けたばっかりで
あのこのてっとしゃべるように名付けたんですけれども
まああの僕がこう考えるその穴さーんくるってことを獲得するとまぁ
例えば違った世界が見えてきたり自分が違ったものに感じられたりとか
新しいチャンスが見えてくる
でそういう話を今日しようと思います
ちょっと広告業界で有名な理論があるんですけども石切り場理論っていうのがあるん
です
それはたとえ1子を切る仕事があると黙っていい子を切らせているとそれはただの奴隷
の労働みたいな形でとっても苦しい作業になるんですけれども
例えばその意志が
教会になるってことを知るとちょっと石をきび目は少し変わってくるんですね
さらに例えば協会に祈りに来る人を交えレーションさせられるとそれは女にし起き
るって行為が違う意味を持ってくるってことがあるんですね
それがまあよく言われるビジョンという言葉であらわされるんですけれども
ビジョンっていうのも実は視点を
今まで見てなかった号るってことの景色を見せることで人の気持ちを変えるという力が
あるんですね
例えば現実世界で言うと
ディズニーランドあるじゃないですか
ディズニーランドというのはホスピタリティがものすごくあるところで
サービスの攻撃もすごく高いですよね彼らはまあアルバイトスタッフのことをキャス
トって呼んでるんですよね
で彼らもまあ例えば掃除をする人もアルバイトの人もミッキーも同じ全出演者だと
バックヤードの裏方ではなくて表に出る人なんだということを
外の与えることで彼らの仕事の意味掃除の意味とは変わってくるとってサービスの
クオリティが上がったりするんですね
で同じようにあのこれはスティーブジョブズは有名な言葉なんですけどもまぁ彼は
アップルのエンジニアに対して僕たちはエンジ色なんじゃなくてアーティストなんだと
いうような
それは工業製品を作るのではなくて人のイマジネーションを掻き立てて世界を変える
作品を作る
我々集団なんだっていう規定を置くことでまあイノベーティブな商品をいっぱい作って
きたと
でまぁアングルを変える視点が変わると見えてくる世界が今まで同じも見てた頭が世界
変わって見えるんですね
そうすると変わって見えたことで人の行動のやり方が変わってくるってことがあります
それがまあビジョンの持つ力なんですけどもそういう概念っていうのは昔の結構日本に
も実はたくさんあったんですけど
と言って念仏と書いたんですけどこれはなまんだぶつっていうのねん6つのことなん
ですけども
この話はちょっとみうらじゅんさん本で勉強したんで正しいからちょっと微妙なとこも
あるんですけども
念仏を唱えるってことの意味っていうのは実は人生のものすごい辛い曲面立った時に
ですねそこがいいんじゃないって
無理やり行ってみるって恋に出して言ってみるって事なんですね
例えば人生を応用に行かないでもそこがいいんじゃないっていうと確かにそんな気に
なってくるというか
例えば命は a に続かないでもそこがいいんじゃないとか
恋愛思うようにいかないでもそこがいいんじゃないって言う
そういうことを言ってみるって事に近い話をしていてぜひこれ皆さんも何か辛いこと
だったために呟いてみると声に出してみると少し脳みそが騙されると思うんですけれど
も
これは念仏が生まれた時代背景というのがとても
飢饉があったり親交があったり病気があったり戦争があったりって生きていく中でもも
すごいとても苦しい時代背景があるんですねそんな中で
とはいえ現実を受け止めて前をが抜かなきゃいけない庶民の人たちが生きる知恵とし
ソリューションとして念仏ってもが発明されたりですとか
わびさびって言うのもなんか似たような概念なんですけれども
で線の力を機と思い出すと思うんですけどわびさびもまあ例えば応仁の乱から戦国時代
までずーっと争いをしていた日本ては荒廃しきってたわけなんですねその中で薄的にも
ソース貧しい子
たいっていうのが続いたんですある権力者以外は新しいものと美しいものを手に入れ
られない1台が続いた中で例えばは古くなっていく
錆びていくものに対して火を見つけようとか不完全のも欠けているものを美しいって
思って外面を提出したんですね
それはそのものがないって言う
時代の中で豊かに生きていくための生活の知恵であってそれも新たなんですマール社
ソリューションなんですよね
でアングルを変えるヒントっていうのは実は必ず課題の中にあるんですよ
課題の中に相手を考えるヒントがあると思っ
これは身近な例で例えるという間の話を英会話教室を組ん友達がやってたんですね
ビジネスマン向けの
でとはいえば大手には料金対決絶対敵わないので彼がやったことっていうのは日本に
駐在する外国人の奥さんに
やる日本語教室って有始めたんですね
それはまあ英語というスキルは不買うのは変わらないんですけども視点を変えることで
彼は新しいビジネスを生み出していたり
例えば旭山動物園とても有名だと思うんですけども
北海道にある動物園であのかつてはすごく人がパナつつ暮れかけたんですね
その理由は二つあって1個は人気ヒーローの動物いなかったということと
もう1個は札幌から結構遠くていわゆる僻地にあったって場所が良くなかったという
ことがあって正
潰れそうになったとそのとき彼らがとった報道っていうのは行動展示という新しい視点
を動物園に入れたんです
行動展示では普通同部センターおりがあってその中に動物を入れてみんなで見
るっていうのが動物園だったんですけども彼らが作ったのは動物の動きに合わせたおり
をつくるってことをしたんですね
つまり動物を見せるんじゃなくて動物の動く姿を見せる
動物園っていうことをつくってトランスフォームしたんですけど
ん
で動物パイプ動くものとか組んで動いている姿を見るとやっぱ楽しいんですよねそれで
今のが大ヒットがあるんですけれどもこれは実は上野動物園にはできない
ソリューションになっているんですよ
それは行動展示というのは動物の動きに合わせておりを作るのでものすごく広いと塩
いるんです
なんで旭川ってちょっと僻地にあるだ土地だけはあるっていうことが実は地の利になっ
てああいうそうリューションが生まれているというのは背景があります
んで課題というのはまあアイディアだったりソリューションだったりイマジネーション
を生み出す原動力なるって事があるんですね
どんどんいきますけど例えばですね老眼鏡これはすごく僕大嫌いな名前でですね僕も
38そろそろ5かける100なんですけどをかけたときてやっぱりショックを受けると
思うんですよね
なんか老眼鏡をかけるとしになっちゃってるっていう
こういうのも例えばリーディンググラスと呼んでみようよと読書する時のメガネなんだ
みたい呼ぶと書ける人の気持ちが変わるはずなんですよ
逆に言うとまたリーディーグラスを持ってないんだっていうのが知的なオシャレ
アイテムになる可能性もあったりですとか
例えば介護ベットもこのやっぱり寝る人の気持ちを考えた時に介護ペットの世話にな
るってやっぱり
心理的に辛い部分があるんですよ
例えばアシストベッドと呼んでみようよと彼は首にあのヘルに上がって朝起きるの結構
つらいんですけども
例えば介護ベットいうの起き上がる機能があったらそれはそれですごく便利だと思うん
ですね
出会い多機能を介護って言わずに高機能なベッドとして売ったらもしかしたら
ターゲットが広がるかもしれないとか
あのそういう人がいる人の気持ちが変わるかもしれないみたいな形してアングルを
変えるとか相手を考えると美品とっての課題の中に潜んでいるという
もう一個あの
8アングルを探すヒントなんですけどもそれは
ものの良さというのは必ず長所と短所でできてるんですね
光と闇の関係性で人間っての悪いとこばっか目につく生き物なんですよね
影があるって言うことはその影をずっと見続けた先には必ず光があるんですよ
逆転できる何かがあるんですね
ねこれは明治大学の齋藤教授って人が書いた本で
世界一節が弱い日本人みたいなタイトルだったんですけどもまぁざっくりいうと日本人
というのはフィジカルが遺伝子的に最も弱い民族だみたいなことを書いてるね
例えば人類が思われたふり母って生まれた黒人の方が一番フィジカルが強くて次に白人
の人でアジアの中でも中国と韓国の人は日本人より平均身長とかすごく高いんですよ
なんで彼の仮設で言うと争いごとが嫌いでフィジカルが弱かった人たちがこう
逃げて逃げて最後に行き着いたのが東島ないんじゃないかってちょっと悲しい仮説なん
ですけども
ただこのアナのワールドカップ予選とか見ていると確かにフィジカルの弱さだったら
どうしても感じるんだよね
もそのフィジカルではそのやっぱり強みに変えることができて
例えばまパリでは超熟っていうすごい柔らかいフォンが大ヒットしているんですよ
でフランス人がフランスパン店はものすごく硬いんですけど日本人がばあれはちょっと
きついということですごい柔らかいものを作ったん
で人間っていうのやっぱり易きに流れるところがあって1回のファーファ観を堪能する
ともう戻れない人も結構出てくるんですよ
もしれって何から同じ発明であれはなんかまぁどんなが来日するときにをしれっとに
会いに来たっていうぐらいファンもいたりするんですけれども
でまぁお尻を洗うっていう画期的なんですけど何がすごいっていうと
連座を温めようっていうそれも繊細なフィジカルの感覚を持ってえっとああいう発想
っていうのは思いつかないんですよね
たの
白人の方は便座を温めるなんて思ったことないと思うんですよ
でもイノベーションというのはまあテクノロジーから生まれるもんなんですけども
もちろんテクノリーム
強いんですけどそういう人間の感覚フィジカル
人間中心のイノベーションというのもあるんですよ
それはパンが柔らかくするとかを知るとみたいなと思うんですけどそういう才能が日本
人にはすごいあると思っています
栗東松の裏側まああの必ず端子の裏柄長袖ならですね
でこっからが僕は今日一番話かかったことなんですけど僕は今日ここに来たのはあの皆
さんの未来に対するアングルを変えてみたいな
で今日この資料技が用意したんです
で今未来ということを考えるときに日本ってやっぱりどうしても閉塞感があったり
漠然とした不安感があるんですよね
今日本に希望があるっていうとちょっと大丈夫間みたいな感じが僕をしてやっぱ直感的
に今この国に未来があるな b づらいんですよねその原因っていうのは少子化高齢化
へネイビーとなっている
課題が山積みなんですよ
でも世界有数の課題先進国なんですね
でもこれはまたチャンスと捉えることもやっぱり出来て
っていうのは今日本が直面している課題っていうのは必ずいつか世界が直面する課題な
んですね
世界の誰よりも先にその課題にトライアルできるチャレンジできるということが実は
凄いアドバンテージになる可能性があるんです
環境問題の課題でトヨタ自動車プリウスってハイブリッド車を作ったように
例えば誰も向き合ったことのない課題に向き合ったときに日本の新しいアイディアとか
ソリューションとかイノベーションが生まれて来るきっかけになる可能性があるって
いう風に僕を持っています
で叶えこそが日本資源だというふうに思った方がいいと思うんですね
でさらにまあ2020年のオリンピックが始まるんです
んいやをなく6年後に日本つが以上に世界から中国受けるタイミングがやってくるん
ですね
そのタイミングであらゆる課題に対するソリューションプレゼンテーションできたら
日本の未来とちょっと変わっていくと思うんですね
ソリューション先進国になる可能性も実はある
でその時に一番必要なものがあるんですけども
それっていうのがあの考える人ですねそして挑戦する人ってのがいないとこの問題解決
していかないですね僕はてっとにすごく期待しているのは
こんな日曜日には頭がこのプレゼンを聞きに来るって言うのはとかいい
ユーストで見るとかサイズサイトで見るって言うとはやっぱり意識は僕はすごい高い人
だと思っているんです
そういう人たちに未来を作る側に行って欲しいなと思って
他のコピーライター飲んで今日皆さんためにスローガンを書いてきました
今スローがのこれです
シンクディファレント and just do eat って言うこれは僕のコピー
でも何じゃなくてシンクディファレントいったまあアップルの有名なコピーで just
do it ってはナイキの夢がコピーなんですけども
この2つを合わせた精神っていうのはたぶんこれから日本にとって凄く大事だと思っ
てるんですね
それは人と違うことを考えるって事とさっすぐやろうっていうその二つの気持ちって
思ってる人がどんだけ日本に増えるかということがこれからの日本の未来を変えていく
と思っていてできれば皆さんにこのスローがが似合う人になってほしいなというふうに
思っています
でまぁちょっとまた別のアングルのことを話したいんですけれども
たまた北ベッド名古屋のスタッフの方にですね
スピーカーの人は今日朝早い集合なんで宿泊しますかって聞かれて
僕は宿泊しますって答えたんですね
で
ちょっと前日に名古屋に入って味噌カツを食べて友だちと青みたいなことでワクワクし
てたんですけども撮っていただいたホテルが
三河安城だったんで1個手前の駅だ車
ペースっ
嘘だろうみたいないや当時作りをみたいな一瞬思ったんですけどさすがにそれを一緒に
やってる学生見えなくてでも
例えば人生のアングルを変えて見てみるってことで上げてそれは今日昨日で言えば凄く
アラナたせいかしちゃったんですけど
あの人生長い目で見たときに1勝でい
未婚男女に泊まる機会って一回かもしれないですよ
そんなものが来ないにドットマンないかもしれないんで実はすごく貴重なよるかもしれ
ないですとか
例えばこのテッドのスピーカー僕はうまくやっぱしゃべりたいと思うんですけど失敗し
てもやっぱりいいと思ったんですよねそれは例えば10年
後の20年前の7月6日何してたかなって考えたときにあの
多分家に行ったら思い出せないんですよね
でペットにこうやってチャレンジしていれば少なくとも自分の中に濃密に残る時間には
なるんですよ記憶に残る違う
で会議失敗したとしてもすごい恥ずかしい思いは当日するんですけどもアフター
パーティで帰ったりするかもしれないんですけどでも10年20年30年というスパン
で行った時には必ず忘れられない時間になっている
ですね
で忘れないない時間に共通していることを一句あってそれは心が動いた時しか人はを
記憶に残らないんですよ
ねここにも来てのドキドキするとかハラハラで何でもいいんですけどそれった僕は生き
てるってこととほぼ同義ぼだなと思っていて
でそういうあの自分の中でずっと残ってる時間見たい事を例えば1日でも1時間でも
増やしていくということを少し意識して生きていくっていうこともとっても大事だなと
思ってい
その時に一つ重要なポイントがあるんですねこれはもう皆さんスピーカーたぶんみんな
言ってたことなんですけど
あの例えばちょっと人にあのめんどくさいなぁとかこの日イベント行くのめんどくない
なとかなんかちょっとアウト強いから ob ホームのアレだなみたいなおっくになる
瞬間ってあるんですけれどもそういうときにちょっとお腹に力を入れて一歩踏み出すと
いうことはとても大事なんですよね
で
あの
ちょっとしたことでいいんですけどなんか脅威
イベントがあるけど枚かなふと3日みたいなことってあると思うんですけどでも
思い切っすごいちょっと力を入れて一歩踏み出すっていうことをできるかできないかと
いうことが結構人生を大きく左右すると思ってるんですね僕はやっぱり何か迷った時に
ちょっとお腹を家から一歩踏み出せる勇気っていうのも
やっぱりみんながもった方がいいと思っているんですね
です最後に僕が
クライアントさんに結構無理なプロジェクト
プレゼンする時の口説き文句っていうのを最後にみなさんに教えてをはにしようと思い
ます
それはですね成功すればヒーローになれます
でも失敗姿勢もチャレンジャーになれますということを言うんです
要は一歩踏み出して損することは1口ないんです
いうことをいつも言ってます
みなさんぜひあのちょっとしたことでいいんで
まず一歩を踏み出すて勇気を持ってください北館スピーチは以上になります